depuis mes 10 ans je tire à l'arc et
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance parce que dès
mes premières années avec beaucoup
d'entraînements j'ai fait partie du top
15 français et j'ai été premier de ma
région de mon département à plusieurs
reprises
enfin
pendant un temps pendant un temps parce
que à mes 15 ans j'ai grandi de 15 cm en
un an et je suis passé de premier
à dernier
je peux dire que c'était quand même
assez triste pour vous faire un schéma
en compétition je tirais à 18 mètres sur
une cible de 60 cm de diamètre et je
m'étais à l'époque 60 flèches sur 60
dans 8 cm dans le jeûne et à partir du
moment où j'ai commencé à grandir
sur mes 60 flèches ben j'en mettais 20 à
côté de la cible
alors avec cette histoire j'aurais pu
perdre pied j'aurais pu penser que
j'étais plus capable que les conseils
que je pouvais donner n'étaient pas ou
plus légitime
et finalement ça a eu l'effet totalement
inverse je pense vraiment que cette
histoire a chamboulé mon caractère à
modifier mon caractère ma façon de
prendre des décisions de manager
également ma perception de l'erreur du
droit à l'erreur alors attention c'est
tout à fait normal d'avoir peur
d'échouer c'est d'ailleurs je pense une
des raisons pour lesquelles un
entrepreneur une entrepreneur
n'ose pas se lancer vous savez ce cette
erreur cette peur d'échouer
pour autant je dis un petit peu réfléchi
et je me suis dit que
cette peur d'échouer est aussi le droit
de se permettre d'échouer
ça venait peut-être d'une sorte
d'éducation collective vous savez de la
culture peut-être notre culture
française comme si c'était honteux
d'échouer
et si on inversait la problématique
j'ai un ami à moi Joseph Ayoub qui a
réalisé une conférence qui se nomme je
vous souhaite d'échouer et il a dit
quelque chose de très intéressant dans
cette conférence il disait que si le
plan a ne fonctionne pas c'est pas grave
puisqu'il y avait le plan B ça on est
d'accord on connaît tous mais si le plan
B ne fonctionne pas c'est encore moins
grave s'il restait 25 lettres dans
l'alphabet et c'est vrai que il avait
raison et depuis que je mets des
centaines de flèches à côté de la cible
même moi aussi j'ai décidé de repenser
ce droit à l'erreur j'ai décidé
d'inverser ma façon de penser depuis
quand j'entreprends un projet je pars du
principe que il réussira et quand je
rencontre une problématique je me dis
que on y trouvera une solution et
attention
échoué peut être une solution voire là
solution une solution qui m'apprendra
beaucoup qui me permettra de gagner en
compétence en expérience et qui me
rendra encore plus légitime auprès de
mon entourage entourage personnel comme
professionnel cet entourage d'ailleurs
qui joue un rôle majeur puisque son
entourage me permet de penser ça et de
réfléchir comme ça que ce soit ma chérie
ma famille mes amis mon associé mon
équipe mes investisseurs ont encore le
théorème ABC avocat dans comptable
consciemment ou non il me permet tous de
dire aujourd'hui devant vous que rien
n'est impossible et quel que soit l'âge
rien n'est impossible
enfin sauf si nous nous posons trop de
questions
vous savez moi je j'adore entreprendre
j'ai toujours voulu entreprendre
malheureusement il y a des projets qui
ont marché très très peu et il y en a
surtout beaucoup qui ont échoué je me
rappelle notamment de quitte ça gogo
drôle de nom on dirait quitte ça gogo
c'était un site de kit graphique gratuit
en clair on permettait au jour de
télécharger des fichiers pour que
eux-mêmes fassent leur site ça cartonne
20 000 téléchargements j'avais je crois
14-15 ans et un jour il y a un hacker
qui arrivait et qui a mis un virus dans
chaque fichier
on a tout arrêté vous en doutez je pense
aussi à autre chose ça s'appelait tweet
au chat deuxième nom un peu bizarre
tweet au chat c'était un service qui
permettait à deux personnes sur Twitter
de se rencontrer sur une plateforme pour
discuter entre elles on a eu le Graal
dès le premier jour des lancements
puisqu'on est arrivé en top tweet en top
tendance sur Twitter
malheureusement le lendemain plus aucun
utilisateur bon
j'adore vraiment entreprendre mais
est-ce que je préfère c'est que mes
projets réussissent vous vous en doutez
et à mes 15 ans j'ai eu une nouvelle
idée une idée qui cette fois-ci venait
d'un besoin d'un besoin que j'ai
ressenti et un service est né il
s'appelle swelo et il permettait il
permet toujours de programmer des
messages dans l'avenir sur Twitter
alors entre nous à l'époque j'ai fait un
site extrêmement moche il était marron
depuis et ça fait 10 ans voire même plus
ça fait 13 ans j'ai toujours pas
rencontré un autre site marron mais là
n'est pas important ce qui est important
c'est que sans le savoir j'ai mis en
ligne mon premier site ce qu'on appelle
un peu un NVP minimum va lui Apple
project en clair j'ai mis un site simple
en ligne très rapidement et ce site
simple est comblé répondait à une
problématique simple
imaginez un instant et si je m'étais
posé trop de questions
et si je m'étais dit que j'allais pas en
être capable ou alors que le site
n'allait pas être assez parfait
justement pour être mis en ligne
parce que je suis un petit peu
perfectionniste
et bien je n'aurais pas été devant vous
ce soir soit l'eau n'aurait pas vu le
jour et je peux vous dire que j'aime
beaucoup être devant vous ce soir
je sais que ce déclic il est compliqué à
avoir vous savez ce déclic de se lancer
d'oser de ne pas avoir peur d'échouer
mais
je pense que chacun de nous vous nous
ici ailleurs on a tous quelque chose que
d'autres n'ont pas on a tous des
connaissances des expériences que vous
allez pouvoir partager vous allez
pouvoir utiliser
je propose de venir avec moi un petit
instant
on fait un saut dans le temps 20 minutes
utilisateurs plus tard mais surtout zéro
euro de chiffre d'affaires plus tard je
suis avec mon associé et puis on se dit
où est-ce qu'on va est-ce qu'on continue
et le projet vivote où est-ce qu'on se
dit non on va aller plus loin on veut
une équipe on veut grandir on décide
d'aller lever des fonds nous voilà un
jeudi soir comment ça à faire un petit
peu nuit on se retrouve face à 10
investisseurs qui sont autour d'une
table rectangulaire qui nous écoutent
certains ne savent pas ce que c'est
encore Twitter c'était à 13 ans
et je me souviens mon associé avait 26
ans j'avais 21 ans j'étais habillé un
peu pareil t-shirt Jean
et on a essayé de les convaincre on a
fait tout ce qu'on pouvait pour les
convaincre j'ai oublié de vous dire
quelque chose on demandait 500000 € on a
vraiment tout essayé et quelques temps
après ils nous ont dit oui
et je me suis toujours demandé mais
pourquoi ils nous ont dit oui bon ce que
je pense c'est ce que j'en ai tiré comme
comme conclusion c'est que on leur a
montré notre expérience on leur a montré
nos compétences et surtout on a parlé
avec passion
et ils nous ont fait confiance on a
réussi à les convaincre et ce n'est pas
les seuls
aujourd'hui selon est toujours à Toulon
dans le sud de la France notre bureau
est à 300 mètres du port avec le soleil
le son des cigales et de deux on est
passé à 3 à 8 à 10 à 13 aujourd'hui et
bientôt 16 on a réussi à convaincre une
équipe qui nous fait confiance au
quotidien et je pense que
par rapport à cette confiance
ça vient aussi du fait que toute notre
équipe a le droit de faire des erreurs
même si ça nous coûte de l'argent du
temps est-ce que c'est un peu ce que
j'ai envie de vous dire n'hésitez pas à
faire des erreurs enfin faites pas
exprès mais je veux dire n'hésitez pas à
vous lancer et à faire potentiellement
des erreurs parce qu'aujourd'hui moi je
le vois chaque membre de ce vélo et
reconnaissant justement d'être autonome
de pouvoir faire ses propres erreurs
je pense vraiment que la légitimité
n'est pas liée à l'âge
je pense que comme je le disais c'est
les compétences c'est l'expérience c'est
ce qu'on vit et c'est aussi ces erreurs
finalement et il y a une citation qui
m'a suivie et qui me suit encore une
citation de Tony gaskins qui dit que
si tu ne suis pas ton propre rêve
quelqu'un va t'embaucher pour te faire
construire les siens
ne le dites pas mon équipe il faut qu'il
reste avec nous
on m'a dit la récemment
la vie sourit aux personnes qui ont
l'audace et qui osent alors oser être
celui et celle sur lequel est laquelle
on mise
je suis une dernière chose
je suis toujours dernier au tir à l'arc
mais j'en suis quand même très très fier
parce que finalement c'est un peu grâce
à ça que je peux vous parler ce soir et
que je suis là
[Applaudissements]